mais bon achat bent riber qu'elle savait
créer un kobe lunery utiliser cet
argument mais non je répète
soir et non pas
comment dire et l'entraînement qui doit
être ferme on me dites pas que vous êtes
venu là vous êtes pointé juste comme ça
une fois vous pouvez me
plaît je crois qu'il ya pas d'autres
miss france musique devait
pas arriver tout seul comme ça du jour
au lendemain vous expliquez
vous parlez tous vu de l'extérieur donc
effectivement je vous parle vu de
l'intérieur il ya une préparation de 1
mois
est ce que vous savez tous les cadeaux
qu'on reçoit mais il ya des filles qui
n'ont jamais pris l'avion on va dans des
destinations de rêve on est hyper
heureuse tous les soirs on a un petit
cadeau sur le lit où on est vraiment
gâté et ça ça n'a pas de valeur et
l'expérience miss france n'a pas de
valeur c'est une personne par région par
année rien que ça c'est c'est
fantastique et toutes les jeunes filles
sa santé que j'ai avec l'onction toutes
les raisons que je suis de gamme ça rêve
de faire ça et ça ça n'a pas de valeur
si maintenant vous dites ok je pose 5000
euros ce matin pour participer à miss
france c'est impossible donc rien que ça
voyez vous voyez la beauté des touches
me regarde et vois le sexisme qui émane
de ce que vous dites alors oui dit que
le pad mister france à mais on s'en fout
c'est la rue même
renouveler le même canal or et ils ont
été considérés comme étant mes temps
soumis en droit du travail ils ont donc
perçu napeo jean-françois de sexisme et
moi je pense que ce concours et les
sexismes ce qui réduit évidemment les
femmes à leur physique mais pas
seulement
[Applaudissements]
les nourrit si on analyse bien le
règlement et le concept de miss france
c'est un concours dans lequel les
français élisent une femme la française
bonne à marier donc pas trop petit pas
trop grosse pas trop vieille célibataire
parce qu'il faut bien faire fantasmer
les hommes donc je trouve ça
profondément at
il mis en avant des critères de beauté
dans lesquelles personne ne se retrouve
jamais des bonbons mais
pas trop et tu te retrouves en d4
il est sexiste et 10-q millan mc vous
regarde moi
ce qui est important c'est de comprendre
c'est que les filles qui sont élues miss
france ce sont les filles qui se voit
georges tu veux le faire tous ces tapis
lui que si quand tu dois parler comme ça
n'aura plus aucune chance à la mer
surtout que si j'avais pas famille
france quelque part on se serait jamais
rencontré
france n'est pas du tout sexistes en
excellent concours
mais tu toujours les mêmes les mêmes les
mêmes critères pour les femmes toujours
sur la beauté
delphine entre sonia rolland autres
vaima la mafia mais l'autre entre autre
bague à la main entre sylvie tellier
entre ce qui t'amène elles sont
tellement que différents c'est vous qui
est réductrice et extrêmement sexy
tendance que nous les mêmes étaient à la
démesure notre avenir je vous promets à
mes fans et pas voyons
toute liberté je vous promets absolument
on vous impose rien vous avez
tourné
en plus de vivre quelque chose
d'incroyable les filles qui gagnent et
même celles qui ne gagne pas les
dauphines elle gagne un job en fait
parce que toutes ses fils un point
obtenu d'être
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui sont influence euse et
gagnent très bien leur vie et toutes les
autres c'est soit actrice animatrice et
voilà et en fait c'est un pont pour elle
c'est un tremplin et encore pendant 10
ans prend plus longtemps on peut être
sur ce tremplin la synthèse d'un
tremplin